hello reject nation I'm Greg Alva this
is Megan Lai Megan Lai you might have
seen on my brother's channel happy
holidays hey it's Milo he gets that
wrong ball [ __ ] play on social media
day
you've heard of jollibee right yeah
spaghetti okay ready
Filipino burgers hello Manila Manoa yeah
so I'm half Filipino and every once a
month I see up everyone's don't wanna
check out a video from the Philippines
because we have Filipino subscribers
that I like to tend to Megan Lang can be
mistaken for Filipino she's not but she
is a patient so she's got that now she's
never seen any of these jollibee
commercials I warned her that I've seen
a few and sometimes they're rather
emotional there's this new one out
called powers no one man should have all
that power that's what this it's a music
video for Kanye West for Jollibee that's
why Kanye West wrote that song years ago
was for John he just did make things
he's a big jolly beat you anyway I don't
know what this one's about I don't know
if it's gonna be emotional I don't know
if this is gonna be alright let's go
let's watch this okay number Danny who
is along hello economize my mailman I
know about know how I move superheroes
Oh
[Music]
if I know Velma wanna know Sabrina
ah sweetie
my daddy to know Allah
[Music]
the case
wonder damn
[Music]
sir what strong fathers that would have
been works rending huh would have been
more relevant when we put this video
lost video that was really sweet I love
how it's like I'm nothing oh look at the
flowers like the only word that is that
whoo USA in Cigala I don't know I
haven't sold into golf since I was 3
years old my family shipped me off to
the Philippines and I was a kid for 3
months should you up to the Scylla penis
yeah they thought it would be cheaper
for me to just go my grandma for 3
months as a kid at 3 years old so they
said we'll meet you on the plane and
they did it your mom's either cruel or
brilliant brilliant really literally I
came back to meet the guy look think
brilliant and then I I forgot all of it
but regardless what I liked about the
trailer is the message of like how being
a parent especially it looks like he's a
single parent yeah how be nice
especially a single pair or any parent
just these normal things are hard to do
and in its own way they can be super
heroic yeah
saving your kid from dying from falling
because the kids an idiot it's a rug how
did he just jet from one room to the
other to save its kid from falling it's
funny cuz it speaks to the older people
who are parents don't get like what you
just said but it also speaks to all of
us who have parents or have had parents
at one time how when you're a kid you
think like your parents are immortal and
they can do any chance they're never sad
or anything like that you know they're
just great and jollibee making people
happy my favorite part is when he said
gret I don't know if like calling an
older lady grandma and the Philippines
is like just the term they use for older
women in the translation as I thought he
was talking to his own
there's only grandma is a grandma and a
gem eat alone now not eating with the
family we're gonna go have this drive
yeah I had to put I had to think about
that for a second
so the giblets are sweet though like to
point out these little thing lifting up
the couch and sweeping did you see that
when he lifted up the couch there was
like a I don't know a watering can or
something instead of that in your
they'll tell enjoys like a trunk yeah
cute I was like that that was awesome
and I don't know these kids the kid and
the dad really bonding him giving him to
chicken I thought it was so sweet don't
keep the tie commercial that kind of
like that it's a daughter and his my
daddy's a liar I don't want yes you're
right yeah that one that one made me cry
oh boy yeah I definitely - every time I
watched it yes
over and over I couldn't stop watching
it
but this one has a much like sweeter you
know it doesn't really tug at the
emotional for as much it's more about
just appreciation and loving in value i
felt like whatever the quality was like
when they cut to this story when he's
talking about his dad and it's like in
letterbox when he's at school it looks
like a shot with like an IMAX camera
look at the letterbox on how much
clearer the quality I'm going to get to
the reality of it everything's much
darker yeah other stuff looking of
commercials because superheroes have to
live in the darkness to provide their
light good wine that's what it's about
good one superheroes make sacrifices
makers were sacrificing he almost didn't
eat dinner I don't think even by itself
dinner he didn't because he can't afford
it and they cut that fun out of you so a
portable seeing youthful makes me eat or
something making you feel full much
agony yeah someone is verbatim
how living hey I would never say that to
anyone I'm really hungry
I would guilt my kids I'd be like I
can't eat because of you have your
stupid jelly beer well good thing you
don't have to
I'd be the villain like that commercial
buildings ah man I should do a vlog
where I go to Jollibee yeah heaven
Jollibee in years I'll go with you I'll
be so much fun nej your spaghetti I've
been there in years you know no they
probably have new things on a menu I do
I'm a simple fries guy oh thank you
filipino french fries taste exactly like
oh there's a basil exactly they should
be Spanish fries in what I would like to
do is try Jollibee in like Glendale out
here and yeah and then go there and then
when I go to the Philippines
try Jollibee there see if it tastes any
different yeah yeah should take it with
you on the plane yeah I'm sitting do a
video where you yeah on the new the one
from America tastes old and cold snail
has nothing to do with the fact that I
waited this long get to the Philippines
to try this burger out jollibee you keep
doing good commercials keep it up hey
hey subscribe to the real rejects if
you're Filipino and you're new or if you
have been here for a while your Filipino
put a comment below I like my Filipino
brothers and sisters and if you're not
don't put any don't put any you belong
here
this is a guy white man yeah segregation
is with this channels all about
yes yeah I don't believe in diversity
Trump's America Megan Lai that's me
this is my social media hood she's
originally from Indiana where Mike Pence
is Governor oh that's something about a
little bear singing about her horrible
I do not represent that she came out
here to spread the word of pence that's
exactly what she told me I said lady you
gotta come on my channel we don't
believe in satire is is all facts check
her got a social media sadness name is
Megan way and check out our patreon have
a good day